coach sa could you talk about the last
play and what made that one the best one
that that you wanted to go
with uh we called three
plays um one they called timeout one we
call timeout and the last one that
didn't work so the fact that it didn't
work made it a really bad
call you know what I mean so um but we
call time out because we had a bad look
we had a good look on the first one uh
they must have known it
um but Tommy just felt like the best
thing that we could do um was have a
quarterback run which was kind of our
two-point play one of our two-point
plays for this game and the ball was on
the three yard line which is just like a
two-point play so but we didn't get it
blocked so it didn't work we didn't
execute it very well and it didn't work
and they pressured and we thought they
would pressure U but we thought we could
Gap them and block them and make it work
and it
didn't next question comes from the
right here hi Jaylen Mark Meers AP radio
how did you see that last play unfold
and and why didn't it work from your
perspective no first thing I'm
appreciative of my coaching staff um for
believing in me to have the ball in my
hands on that last play um you win some
you lose some this all part of the game
you know with anything you know all I
all I came down fall back to your level
of training and we just failed on that
play that's all it was you know cuz at
the end of the day I just trusted the
guys up front for believing me on the
last play to have the ball and
unfortunately we just we just missed and
we just didn't get in the end
zone